[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ryan clark is an espn analyst across
multiple shows including getup
sportscenter with scott van pelt uh on
mondays nfl live on tuesday and more
also stars in a weekly ufc show with uh
uh daniel cormier
uh espn it's called rc and dc and uh
their podcast face first each friday
he's the former defensive back for the
steelers he's ryan clark who joins us on
loan for the mothership uh should that
feel like a win to the kansas city
chiefs last night
yeah i mean when you win the football
game you win the football game and you
know in this league dan it's hard uh to
get w's but
you also have to go in and critique it
even harder with the win you know now
you can be harder on patrick mahomes
harder on travis kelsey you can you know
speak to dan soris and that defense
about giving up the deep ball without it
necessarily feeling like you have to
build these guys up because you do have
a w the kansas city chiefs have a higher
standard than other teams in this league
right now you know we expect certain
things from them and i believe they
expect certain things for from
themselves you know i had colleagues
speaking before the season could the
kansas city chiefs go 17-0 and they're
four and four
yeah but you start to look at this and
now we're seeing defenses basically say
all right let's see if you can be a
conservative offense or you're not going
to hit those home runs
why did it take so long for defenses to
kind of figure this out of not let
mahomes throw those deep balls to tyreek
hill
maybe it sounds simpler than what it is
ryan
you know what it's actually pretty
simple if you go back to last year dan
and i said this uh and i spoke about it
on tv
rahim morris and atlanta falcons when
they played the kansas city cheese late
in the season i want to say kansas city
scored 16 17 points that game it was in
a win because atlanta was terrible but
they played a too high shell then they'd
rotate a safety every now and then to
kyrie killed on those deep crossers that
he'd get from trips formations and it
worked and then if you watch the super
bowl the tampa bay buccaneers even
though they were able to rush
the passer because they had so many
injuries on the front line of the kansas
city chiefs 10 buccaneers did the same
thing and so what it does is it makes
patrick mahomes play slow as well i mean
he famously admitted himself that he
couldn't read defenses till you know
halfway into the year he was the
starting quarterback and i think by
making him play slow by making them earn
it by forcing them to run you know teams
are making them conservative and
honestly quite boring dan and you know
that team likes to have fun and so
they're gonna have to adjust and learn a
new identity
can patrick mahomes be a game manager
oh i believe so but uh he's obviously
too talented to ever
just be that uh what patrick mahomes has
to be though is more accurate right
patrick mahomes has to be more efficient
patrick mahomes has to be a quicker
decision maker and he also a little bit
has to not be patrick mahomes and what i
mean by that is he doesn't need the big
play all the time you know sometimes
it's okay to hit the smart play
sometimes it's okay to get the check
down and he's gonna have to fight
against that himself
you and your prime against tyree kill or
travis kelsey
who do you want i would definitely i
would definitely want travis kelsey
because tyrion hill got some stuff i
don't got you know at least travis
kelsey i just stay close hey dan if
if it's tyree hill and it's just me
that's probably over before it starts
and that's terrible coaching and that's
what coach lebo would have decided to do
what's that feeling like when you watch
somebody run by you and you know that
you don't have that makeup speed
well you know what it's it's one you're
pissed off at yourself and you're upset
with yourself because you could have got
you should have got back a little deeper
if you knew you couldn't run with them
and it's honestly just sheer pain right
you know the the everybody stands up in
the stands people start screaming and
you're so scared that you can't look
back for the ball and all you're doing
is waiting for the inevitable which is
the touchdown it's one of those moments
it's one of those moments where you
realize you know what some people just
left the hospital with a little more
than others
we're talking ryan clark former nfl
defensive back and of course works for
the mothership are the saints okay at
quarterback
you know what i i think they can be you
know we haven't gotten to see trevor
simeon play uh
quarterback in a long time obviously he
had a great year at denver and many
people thought that he could be the
future starter or franchise guy there
and we felt like sean payton is the
quarterback of whisperer i mean to be
honest wasn't that why we were so
excited about jameis because we've seen
sean payton be successful with taysom
hill we've seen him he's successful with
teddy bridgewater and so when you look
at what trevor simeon was able to do
yesterday coming i mean uh two days ago
coming into the game against the tampa
bay buccaneers i mean he looked
extremely competent this defense is a
defense that can keep you in game so
they can be okay moving forward or at
least as okay as they were with jameis
winston they still need to add a pass
catcher so you're hoping michael thomas
can come back healthy off the ir yeah i
mentioned this earlier that i would
reach out and see if denver be willing
to part with teddy bridgewater since
he's already had success there knows the
offense and would probably be an upgrade
over trevor simeon therefore i can keep
taysom hill maybe at that
all-purpose position and and you know
because you're lacking offensive weapons
yeah i i don't think i don't think
moving taysom hill to the quarterback
position is the effortless team i even
believe if you go back to last year
especially late in his run you know you
look at philadelphia
uh in game four last year he was kind of
being fine found out they were figuring
out that he couldn't push the football
down the field that he wouldn't get out
of the pocket and run as often as he was
or would when he was the wildcat
quarterback and so i believe keeping
chase him where he is at that hvac being
able to play quarterback is the thing to
do and if you can't get teddy
bridgewater back i believe that's
something you do uh the thing we don't
know is what they see in trevor simeon
drew brees kind of spoke about it on the
broadcast this week that he said trevor
simeon is more than competent is more
than capable of being the starting
quarterback of that team and i think
sean payton if he's seen enough is
willing to do that the rams picking up
von miller means what
it means that the rams are all in on
winning the super bowl right now also it
means how in the hell or who in the hell
is manipulating the salary cap in los
angeles you know some people like like
some people can't keep one cornerback
and you know they've been able to
assemble you know probably this
era's best edge rusher obviously this
era's best d tackle and the best
cornerback in the game um i think they
decided that you know they're going to
rush the passer they're going to get to
the quarterback and they're going to
score points offensively i know von
miller was a little bit sad yesterday
and you can kind of see the emotion when
he spoke leaving denver but i'm sure
that all changed when he remembers that
aaron donald gets double and triple t
and that he's going to have one-on-ones
all day oh i thought it was a must-cry
situation for von miller but deep down
he's going hell yeah
hell yeah i get out of here i'm going to
la i got a chance to play in the super
bowl uh before i let you go you faced
adrian peterson that the titans are
coming you know going to reach out and i
guess bring him in uh
i don't know what he's got left but uh
what was it like to face adrian peterson
in his prime
oh it was absolutely it was absolutely
terrifying because he was a guy that had
first round talent obviously but he's
top 10 pick seventh pick of the draft
but he ran like an undrafted free agent
you know like he ran like every every
time he got the football that he was
fighting for his career and or his life
and when you have to tackle a man who
has no regard for his own body that's a
that's a very scary proposition and you
know he's one of the best ever do it
he's obviously a hall of famer we don't
know what he has now but he was the
derek henry of his time he was the guy
that was without a doubt far ahead of
any other runner in the game and you
know it's good to see him back hope he
gets another opportunity but man i sure
do miss the uh the old all day yeah he
rushed for 140 yards against your uh
steeler defense in 2013.
yeah i remember that dan thanks a lot
what is that like though when you know
that this guy it's going to hurt like
this guy's running and i gotta hit him
it's my job
he's got 60 pounds on me
what's that like
i mean i think i think i think it's one
of those things it's just why you do it
you know i think it's why we're kind of
all screwed up in the head uh you know
it actually it actually excites you
because you want to see if you can win
who the better man is uh or who we
obviously know who the bigger man is but
who the better man is uh when you get
your opportunity and so for me that was
always the challenge in it you know can
you step up and do some things that
quote unquote normal human wouldn't
attempt to do and so uh that's why we
love ball
ryan great to talk to you again thank
you my best to uh the guys on getup
thanks for joining us thank you so much
man you have a great day
that's uh ryan clark yeah i can't
imagine what's that that's like i know
it's your job but when you see that
running back a physical running back
like jerome battis derrick henry and
they come through the line and you're
there
and you gotta try
but
how do you try without trying too hard
where you know it's gonna really really
hurt